My sister Arden sacrificed her whole
life for this tournament.
"... and through her bravery humankind
pushes on with dreams of tomorrow."
There's just one problem:
- "Eight billion people watching and
her nose looks crazy shiny."
"What? Like you weren't thinking it."
"Matter transference will commence
in three... two... one..."
- "Wha...?"
- "Oh, thank God, we can finally switch plac-"
- "We can't switch."
"You've got to win this tournament, Victoria."
"You've gotta win the whole thing."
- "What?"
- "Remind me again what happens
if I just quit and come home."
- "Aliens invade the earth and kill everyone
you've ever cared about."
(crowd screaming)
- "That's like a hundred percent for sure?"
-"This is not a pageant."
- "Really? Because I just spent the last week starving to death next to a woman who wanted to kill me."
"Seems pretty similar."
- "Too slow."
- "You know some people respond better to positive encouragement."
- "The other competitors are
going to do a lot more than hurt your feelings."
- "Oh, come on."
"Still not hearing positive vibes."
- "You're the hero, Vic. Better get used to it."
What makes you think you can take on the most powerful force in the universe?
- "Don't you get it? They chose the right sister after all."
Let's go finish this tournament.
Who am I?